let's talk about the best foods to
consume for reducing a fibroid a fibroid
is a tumor that's growing on the inside of the
uterus and they can sometimes grow in different
parts of the uterus but they could be the
size of a pea to the size of a basketball
so the main thing you need to know is
you want to avoid foods that cause growth
cheese is filled with hormones and
you definitely want to avoid cheese
and that is because milk helps a baby calf grow
into a cow so milk has all sorts of growth factors
and of course they make cheese out of milk now
soy is another plant that is very estrogenic
so you want to stay away from all versions of soy
you want to stay away from anything that increases
estrogen and that includes flaxseed as
well now in addition to that you want to
avoid foods that trigger insulin because
insulin is a very powerful growth hormone
and of course you'd want to go low carb and
low sugar but here are the foods that have
various phytonutrients that can help decrease
inflammation decrease fibrosis and decrease
angiogenesis which is the formation of new
blood supply to a fibroid so number one berries
number two garlic three cauliflower four tomato
five onion six broccoli sprouts seven peppermint
you can do that in a tea or blend in with certain
foods number eight shallots which are like these
baby little onions and then we have peanuts which
will give you some resveratrol which can also be
found in red wine but the problem with that is
the alcohol um doesn't really help you shrink
your fibroids and lastly fasting intermittent
fasting and periodic prolonged fasting is probably
one of the most powerful things you can do for
fibroids so if you combine that with healthy
keto and make sure you have some of these foods
right here i think that would be a perfect plan
hey before you go real quick i have
a course entitled how to bulletproof
your immune system it's a free course
i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today